[Music]  foreign  [Music]  what are you doing tossing you over the  gate  I didn't mean right that second I meant  after I was ready I wasn't even done  talking toss you over the gate don't  touch over the gate make up your mind  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  don't just take stuff  [Music]  but I guess that's what it's here for  [Music]  I just saw on the calendar that right  now on Earth it's almost Christmas time  we don't have time for trivialities like  Christmas but Peter's so sad about  Gamora being gone  we go to Earth they're a really  wonderful Christmas gift  [Music]  something special you will never forget  what about someone special  [Music]  we are looking for the legendary Kevin  Bacon we're looking for the legendary  Kevin Bacon your voice is small and  Mastery I think maybe you didn't hear  you  haha  you come with us as a Christmas present  [Music]  [Music]